hello can you hear me hi Bill how are
you it's Jim and Dan Soder and Sam hey
what's going on good
hey buddy I'm actually hitting the
buttons today yeah all very nice yes I'm
the designated button pusher it's going
well
what's up buddy nothing man a whoring
myself out to promote a new special
that's what I'm doing when are you
airing when does it first want to come
on I need you shot one I didn't know it
was airing yet it came out yesterday on
that foot Oh congratulations
what's it called called walk your way
out that's great dude hey you just and
by the way it's unfortunate that you
shot it because you just had a baby so
I'm sure you're already gearing up with
material yeah you know I'm trying to
find a balance of that because I don't
want to be the guy we just talked about
and then my kid said this but I was like
I I don't want to be the be strictly dad
comedian but uh I think eyes like you
know Rogan and Chapelle and them they
have kids and they they still talk about
all the crazy stuff and then they'll
touch on stuff about the kids I'd like
to do it more that way because it really
becomes an isolating thing for I think
crowd members if they don't have kids or
even if they have kids and they just
want to get away from it with more [ __ ]
about their kids though give your uh did
you come on time like with the due date
no it's a couple weeks late I always
have a weekend days late yeah yeah but
you know the thing about it is is when
they fix a date they're just guessing I
mean they don't know when you banged and
actually you know they take it you know
it's like a point spread for a football
game like a baby
Patriots by three now do they yeah do
they set it like the way Vegas makes are
through it like a shitty like Rhode
Island Casino where you're like ah this
is going to be way off that's they're
pretty good about it because it kind of
likes De Niro and Christina like I was
definitely like she was definitely late
but yeah man it's a hell of an
experience I'll tell you that when uh
you know when they get coming in they're
like I swear to God I was joking on
Kimmel
when I dropped my wife off to the
emergency room she goes alright you got
a park down there and as I drove down to
go park the car there was this voice in
my head that just said what if I just
drove away you leave to go get
cigarettes before you could even tell
them you're going to get cigarette but
if I just would drove into the woods
that just became a mountain man no
there's literally no way to prepare it
in this if you're any sort of life if
you have an even an ounce of humility in
yourself that you're not you're not
going to feel like you're ready for it
on any level and uh it was you know but
then the Advocate and you just like you
just settle into the thing we're trying
to hold we're trying to do the babies
are mine and Jesse's baby's due in like
a week or so but I have to travel like
really close to around the due date for
a day so we're trying to figure out how
to rush it along and we were at the
doctor's yesterday and the doctor like I
had no idea this is even a thing but the
doctor suggested nipple stimulation they
were like if you set if you stimulate
the girdle the woman's nipples it
releases some kind of like chemical or
hormone and the baby comes out quicker
if you stimulate nipples really yes well
this is what I've learned going through
this is that everybody has a series it's
Bisson to it but life I'm sure you've
noticed this Sam it's these people who
have kids they're not sane most of them
are not sane and after a while you just
got to kind of like just like not making
eye contact kind of be looking forward
and just sort of you know nodding as if
you're engaging in that yeah yeah I just
I just tune them out you have literally
told people I've told people about how
crazy parents are and they go yeah I
know right and then they literally do
what I say that other people do and I
might be doing it right now
let me bring an unbelievable level of
anxiety like you're having a kid or
watch out everything's going to change
and I have like this ominous tone it's
like isn't it a good thing don't you you
felt like you resent your child like I
think a lot of people they resent their
kids more like somebody thinks they're
breaking ground they go like one
hope you're getting your sleep now
because all really do babies cry at
night I don't think that's ever been
pointed out I know it still I hate when
I go hey get some sleep like you can't
like yeah it's not wrong a minute first
night you only get three hours please
screw you're done you're going to be
tired I can tell you right now the other
night I was so tired my wife was going
to get the pacifier and I was just
starting to choose talking to me bring
the pacifier over and I was so
sleep-deprived I just walked towards the
noise and I literally started to put the
pacifier in her mouth did she laughs
thought I was making a joke yeah I mean
I just put it in her mouth I just was
going towards the mouth but she thought
I was joking then she realized I wasn't
she just like laughs it was like yes so
all like you know what you can do
because you're going to feel useless
because you know they're breastfeeding
they're doing everything I just changed
every diaper I can anytime the baby
starts to cry I could sit up like like
The Manchurian Candidate sacred changer
and hand her off to her and my wife told
me she said it's been a godsend that
you're still engaged and all I'm doing
is changing the diapers Kiko and 90% of
it meant did you when were you in the
delivery room did you watch yeah yeah I
was fun amazing if I stayed north of the
curtain which I definitely recommend
Angela said all really say Stan but yeah
I I didn't I didn't break down and cry
and all this stuff that people said you
were going to do and I really thought
there was something wrong with me
because at one point they're going to
leave you alone with your kid
if they go back to your wife for the
first time and I was waiting for all
this cliche things to happen and when it
didn't happen I literally put my head
down in the bassinet I was thinking like
oh my god I'm a serial killer come on
with me and what I realized was I was I
was trying to live other people's
experience though it wasn't until I sort
of relaxed like 12 hours later it hit me
I was just like wow I really get what I
mean but I never became this blubbering
idiot which I think I think a lot of
that exaggerated is to be honest with
you maybe I'm just saying that to make
myself feel better so you think they
dress it up like do when they do a
biography and they make everything more
dramatic
it's all just in hindsight I think
that's exactly what I think parents
actually compete stories to talk about
ah how changed like everything just
change like I don't even look at it
share the same I can't listen to Harry
Chapin anymore yeah it's so it's so over
like overly done it's like no I got a
kid I got a I have a responsibility and
I'm going to I'm going to crush this
thing and I'm going to screw up and but
I will you know someday when my kids
comes to me today you know my sixth
birthday you said Slovak challenges that
the other thing and this just really
hurt me I'd be like you know what I'm
sorry I did that and I'm actually going
to give her like closure on it as
opposed to like my generation where it's
just like you know you're going to carry
that crap for the rest of your life do
you think it's something when you were a
kid and go like I'm not going to do that
to my daughter or my son do you think
like I'm not going to do that yeah I've
already done that like I definitely you
know there was a lot of name-calling
when I was growing up so I just sort of
made it a rule in my head along so I've
never called a woman a [ __ ] that I've
dated ever I've never I've never done
any of that name-calling wow I didn't
like it I saw what it did one time in 14
years with my wife I said you're being a
[ __ ] and she knew how important it was
to me to never repeat that mistake and
she rubbed that in until I finally just
I just called it on and I go you know
what USD there's a certain level of like
joy and a sense of accomplishment that
you feel that you finally got me to say
that and I think it's disgusting I'll
see laughs and then we sort of had it
out and she never brought it up again my
wife's distinct but they all got that
thing where they like this it's been
nuts you don't it is about women is
because generally speaking unless you're
dating like an MMA fighter like they
women can't beat the [ __ ] out of you so
they are so good at just like
controlling you like this with little
manipulation think so but if you have
something when you're really strong like
they look at that the way Tom Brady
looked at like a nickel defense
keep it I got a beat there I got I got
two wanted to find a way through this
the other emotional bullet they like
emotionally bully you it's it's I mean
if you were to cycle w but like I just
think it's it's more of a survival thing
where it's like they need to have
control in that area where if you're
actually look there with the guy who's
physically stronger than them and
mentally stronger than them that's
getting set match they're not going to
get anything so I think that they you
know right if I mean I I think will easy
mas well well I could pick up heavy
stuff and that's what work that's what
we're bringing to face that's why that's
why we lose so much I'm amazed you never
called a girl like I've done nothing but
name-calling and it does get really ugly
in a relationship and you never like
called a girl a contour said funk like
you oh you purposely avoid it yeah no
and it's because it just breathes this
resentment it's a it's just it's not a
it hurts them in a way that like it
wouldn't really hurt a guy cuz they're
more in touch with their feelings you
really hurt him so I saw that and I
didn't want to repeat that and I find I
got way more mileage out of saying
things like you know like what I do
whatever the hell I get said about you
know and you're using that right now and
you feel a sense of triumph you go like
that and you know as long as you come at
them like an adult and if you admit when
you're wrong when you are wrong and you
apologize it gives you so much
credibility when you're actually calling
them out on stuff if every time they
come at you you start frothing at the
mouth then you just become an [ __ ]
right like if when you're wrong be like
you know what you're right I should have
done that and you actually try and work
on it it gives you credibility that
you're trying and then you know because
the thing is once we look at you like
you're just you're going to mad dog them
every time like once a woman just like
crusts over it you've done the
relationships over and and then it's
just going to go down that road that
we've all been on as comedians we've all
been on that road and it's you know and
I figured by the 20th time down that
road I didn't want to go down your last
night and it never goes away either like
the name
Halling they will remember that forever
and then ankle no because I know because
it will come up again and again and
again and the further removed you are
from when you first did it the less that
the anger that you felt even exist
because you don't even remember why you
were angry you don't remember and you
just sound like an [ __ ] because she
will bring it up again well you call me
a [ __ ] what you call me this what you
call me this I told my ex - shut up a
couple times while we were arguing like
shut up shut up
and Dallas I got that thing where she
was like don't ever [ __ ] tell me to
shop and I was like but I was we were in
a fight now it's like shut up you're not
making a good point and it was like it
was like a real bit have you ever called
a girl a [ __ ] or a [ __ ] ah not a [ __ ]
but I think I called a girl a [ __ ]
before three of you agree I'm wrong I'll
say yeah I can't believe that I thought
everybody did that you're gonna be a
rageful guy yeah I said everyone did
that you do it in the car you pretend
she's hitting a bar yeah good shower
fight real like you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
just screaming it in the shower
so even salad is an echo so they're
gonna do yeah but it's reverb and it
sounds more like a guitar trick yeah I'm
a big I'm a big letting it out in the
car by myself and then looking over at
somebody at a red light and they're just
looking at me like well your face is not
red anymore it's starting to go back to
normal color oh yeah oh yeah somebody
like those oh I I gotta watch out for
things like if you're in the middle of
an argument I say you you and me a fight
and then you leave the house and then
later worry whatever she goes all right
look I don't want to fight are you able
to turn off being angry like I would
always stay angry and wreck things
you're able to go like all right she
said she was sorry or she's done
fighting I can kind of move forward now
I'm working on that that's something we
had like a big fight about where I would
just be like well look just because
you're saying you're sorry and you're
done doesn't mean I'm not still angry
and I realized that part of me that was
okay to say but there was another part
of me that like people I grew up with we
didn't let stuff go and then we didn't
apologize you just sort of randomly
started talking about sports or the
weather later I was not
a functional thing so I have the problem
of when we get into fights of digging in
but like I could think about my wife is
I can't stay mad at her for too long a
time it just after a while just like a
come on you get over here you can't stay
mad at or so
yeah like when I fight like I just need
to be especially once we get to a place
where it's just going in circles like if
you just leave me alone for 25 minutes
it dissipates yeah I could just be fine
like if you will just leave me alone
for 20 minutes 25 minutes it's all going
to go away but she never shall never
like she needs that sort of like no tell
me it's okay be okay right now just say
the words and make it okay and just make
it stop
and that's why just goes forever oh I
can totally know that feeling and that's
I'm actually picture and you're trying
to walk away the more the more you walk
away the faster she's walking towards
that you literally attract what you fear
that's the work I would just say listen
you just respect the fact that I need
ten minutes yeah yeah promise you I'm
not going to go out the window and leave
you forever just let me just go in the
other room for ten minutes so I can come
back as an adult like you literally have
to the worst your step you take Jake
with dicey did he just [ __ ] off for a
few minutes you [ __ ] [ __ ] like you
can't do that sure can't do it yes be
mature yeah I admire your ability to do
that man annoys not respect that that's
great you can do it so and you probably
think not even a baby like okay I don't
want to yell in front of the kid the way
they yelled in front of me or like you
probably think like I don't want to do
the same [ __ ] ever
I don't like dude I'm literally like I
meditate I'm actually going to go talk
to a therapist like about blood gases
right now you know what the reality is
I'm not even angry anymore I just have
to believe that I'm not angry I just my
problem is I don't have any middle
ground emotions I go from totalitarian
out - what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] tons in
life you know in two seconds so I need
to I need other options yeah you can't
just go yeah zero to 60 the entire times
not the way to go
I got this new thing I do when I'm
driving where when somebody cuts me off
and does an [ __ ] move I just think
like I've done that or yeah that's it
that's a nice move try to like applauded
you respect the game oh that's great I
hope seen that one before I think he's
doing it he's really doing it I just do
this narky kind of like thing or if I
try to not be mad I do a thing where I
go cool oh that's so cool I'm actual
[ __ ] furious cool 20 at that I can
still hear the rage in your voice when
you stay cool yeah cool
oh cool I'm so happy for his [ __ ]
cover decieving under that that's a
great way to get crowd raised the move
well I made a project I'm trying to list
I don't ever want to yell in front of my
kid I'll talk about that in common cones
like you gotta yell I'm like no I'm not
because you gotta forget I'm telling you
you gotta but like the thing is is I
don't like hey Bill Wonder my
interruption fellas but not in the show
hold on there Jim and Sammy boy you got
to end the old radio program in just 60
seconds
sorry about that bill that's it that's
real because the computer cuts us off so
that's our little warning so not
knowable the network vacuum
bill burr what what's it called again
bill walk your way up walk your way out
I saw the promo for it I'm happy for you
it is on Netflix right now yeah so go
home and watch it and give it I'm sure
it's brilliant and give it a great
review and congratulations man to you
and me on the baby and I'm really really
happy for you dude congratulations dude
thank you buddy all right Sammy - thanks
guys yeah man patrisse benefit oh god
everyone first yeah yes the regular some
of us are on a Leslie Jones is on I'm on
and doing Anna's on it very excited
I see Collins on and I'm not sure I only
is he not on it I don't know Collins on
it he should be if he's not maybe he
wasn't available this year and they're
going to cut us off you a plug
I'm going to be at st. Louis helium
February 9th through the 11th okay and I
just catch my UFC podcast Sam
the wrestling podcast yeah and the
bonfire Mondays and was this yes sixty
eight pm on comes to tree I believe
that's it